hi guys dr. Berg here in this short
video we're going to talk about
non-alcoholic fatty liver disease so
many people have a fatty liver and it
doesn't necessarily it's not really
coming from drinking too much alcohol
there's other reasons for that the main
reason is insulin resistance and I want
to explain that if you haven't seen the
other videos I'll put some links down
below but this is very important
see insulin is a hormone that helps
regulate blood sugars a lot of people
associated with diabetes but insulin is
the hormone that if even in a small
amount it converts food especially
carbohydrates to cholesterol and fat and
it really loads up that liver with fat
so in the presence of a little too much
insulin you're going to get a fatty
liver and it may not even show up is a
weight problem at first but it will
probably show up in the midsection
as far as a fatty gut in fact and this
is just my opinion I think because I've
tested it so many times I've sent people
to the read out radiologists to get
ultrasounds in the liver if you take
someone with a gut they have a fatty
liver a lot of times when the liver
fills up with fat spills over into the
gut and you have this roll around the
top section where we have this protruded
belly which is a whole other thing but
here's what happens the problem with
this fatty liver is that you don't
really have any symptoms for a long time
the liver has to be almost completely
destroyed like 90% before even shows up
on a blood test so you don't even know
you have it and it doesn't create any
problem until later in life so you when
you're surprised so I'm just bringing
your awareness up because what's
happening at the cellular level is
turning into cirrhosis that's scar
tissue the liver is becoming like
fibrotic and so it's going to lose
function over time and it might show up
in arthritis and joint problems and
fatigue but it might not at first but
the point is that you need just to be
aware of this is a serious problem down
the road
so you got the cirrhosis this liver roll
and what's happening is the body is
releasing insulin and insulin resistance
is when the insulin is no longer being
accepted like it should in the
ever so the liver is blocking it it's
resisting it and so the signal goes back
to the pancreas and says hey it's being
blocked it's not going in I can't hear
you so then the pancreas starts
producing more insulin because the
return messages the feedback is not
connecting so it's kind of like talking
to your your child telling to take out
the garbage they're not listening you're
going to increase the volume start
shouting at them and so that's what's
happening right here so we have this
five to seven times more insulin pumped
up by the pancreas then normal people
and what's going to happen is that's
going to create a huge problem with the
liver it's going to start getting fatter
and fatter and fattier I remember there
was my patient this one guy came in he
had 95% of his liver was completely
filled with fat and I remember his eye
looking at his abdomen it was all
distended and sticking out and he was
doing ice cream every single night so I
know you're not doing that you probably
know people who do that but if you've
been watching my videos your diets
probably absolutely perfect right now
but here's some solutions to correct
this first of all you have to know the
liver is the one of the only organs that
can take a real big beating and
regenerate a hundred percent liver
tissue can come back that's the good
news the bad news is it takes a bit of
time it could take up to three years of
eating healthy to restore your liver you
can't just do it for two weeks now one
of the best remedies that dissolves fat
is choline and you can buy this from the
health of storr choline and it's
considered a type of B vitamin but it's
really Lippo trophic which helps
dissolve that in the liver and probably
whatever it's recommending I would
triple the dosage start taking that a
regular basis but again I don't want it
I want you to get the impression that
has just taken a pill to fix your liver
you have to fix your whole lifestyle you
have to fix your eating you have to take
a whole body approach because it's not
going to work just to take a pill and
not change your ways cruciferous
vegetables are the other thing that you
need to start consuming because that
will also help that off the live
if you don't if you want something to
enhance it you can do something like
this this is the organic cruciferous
concentrate and you take this you would
probably take nine to twelve of these a
day if you have a fatty liver to help
support the liver to help clean it up so
that's another thing you can do to
enhance your diet but you but you cannot
fix this without actually eating
tremendous amounts of vegetables if you
don't like vegetables you're going to
have to start eating them somehow maybe
in a shake or something but it's almost
impossible to fix this condition if you
don't consume vegetables these other
things are just enhancements they're not
the cure and then the other thing is you
don't want to consume any sugar because
the sugar activates the insulin okay so
we want to avoid the sugar the hidden
sugars add more vegetables choline is a
really good one cruciferous is another
one and again it's it's a little it's
not as easy as doing these there's other
complications you have individual
specific problems if you really are
serious about getting healthy you maybe
want to consider signing up from my
membership site and in that site you
have me to guide you it is do it
yourself but you can always ask me a
personal questions it's improv the most
cost effective way to get help because I
have over two hundred lessons that you
would learn from when I put a link down
below so you can check it out and you
had a month to test it out to see if you
liked it or you can get a refund but
it's it's a great program because you
get all the details of what to eat what
not to eat what to do as far as
techniques remedies things like that and
then you can ask questions and you have
me as your guide but this is a really
good thing to to take the holistic
approach and to give you the knowledge
so you're not at the effect of these
conditions just because you don't have
some you're missing some information so
I like to give you the whole scoop help
you understand it so go ahead and apply
some of these tips right here and I hope
this educated a little bit and so your
next step is to get started